google just announced their pixel 5a and
today we will compare it to the iphone
12 which you can now buy for a lower
price on amazon links down in the
description and we're gonna test out
everything we're gonna compare the new
display the speakers the performance
we're gonna talk about waterproofing
design and much more now i know right
out of the gate this seems kind of like
a boring update but there are some
pretty significant differences that make
this phone quite interesting on the
outside this thing looks pretty much
identical now they call it mostly black
it's a little bit more gray and one
thing that's actually missing right over
here is the laser auto focusing system
now that sounds like a bummer but maybe
google has a trick up its sleeve as far
as software they are always great at
that so we're actually gonna do a blind
camera comparison and i'm very curious
to see how much software improvements
has apple made compared to google that's
gonna be a fun video so if you guys want
to see that click that subscribe button
down below and you guys can help us
reach 1 million subscribers before the
end of the year now this is actually
google's last phone that is going to
include a wall charger this is an 18
watt fast charger to juice this thing up
so that is great to have that in the box
now as far as the actual phone itself
the screen did get larger we'll be
testing out the brightness here in a sec
and so overall it is a little bit larger
than the iphone 12 that one has a 6.1
inch display compared to 6.3 but because
the aspect ratio is a little bit
different and because of the bezels the
width is exactly the same it's just a
little bit taller build quality wise the
iphone definitely takes the win you have
aluminum on the sides and then glass on
the front and the back with wireless
charging compared to metal that is
covered with this rubber texture which
doesn't feel too cheap but it doesn't
feel nice and then unfortunately the
pixel 5a still doesn't have wireless
charging that is a big bummer for me the
5a is heavier at 183 grams compared to
164 and that is mostly because of the
massive battery inside of this thing i'm
excited to use and see how long a guy
can get this thing to last probably a
couple days with heavy use because it
has a 4
700 milliamp hour battery compared to
about 2 800 that is just insane with
that snapdragon processor that's really
efficient of course we have lightning
versus usb type-c and the last thing
with pixel is that it still comes with a
headphone jack which is really
convenient now with the new iphones of
course we have face id you guys saw it
unlocked pretty much instantly you swipe
up and you're in it's fast it's very
secure but with the less expensive pixel
we do have their pixel imprint is what
they call it fingerprint unlock sensor
right there on the back so it's also
nice and convenient and also secure now
the pixels ola display looks to be much
larger even though it's not that much
bigger by the specs maybe because of
that notch or on the iphone so we are
going to put this oled to the test
against apples which is fantastic but
first i want to go ahead and do a
speaker test to see how they compare so
go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right google wow that phone sounds
fantastic
not even counting that it's a budget
phone it is louder the mid sound better
the bass sounds better i mean this thing
they're just pushing it to the limits
the back is all vibrating from the phone
but dang i will take that loudness and
man you guys did a killer job now
getting into the display so far i'm
really pleased with the pixel 5. the
screen is larger it is oled so i want to
go ahead and test out the maximum
brightness a lot of times the iphone
really wins out in this area and
surprisingly looking at these they look
almost identical in terms of brightness
now as far as off axis the pixel does
get quite a bit warmer and dimmer when
you're looking at it from the side but i
am surprised that oled screen is not a
sucky one on the pixel now as far as
contrast and reflectivity the iphone
does do a better job the pixel is a
little bit more reflective but looking
at this hdr image you get a lot more pop
from the iphone so the peak brightness
is better on the iphone for hdr so if
you're going to be watching movies
you'll definitely have a better
experience hdr ways on the iphone but of
course with the iphone you do have to
deal with that notch taking up some of
the screen and the aspect ratio is a
little more square so you do have more
black bars so far i am very impressed
with the pixel 5a but now that we're
getting into performance this is where
we might start seeing some bigger
differences and i'm actually curious
about the 5g
they put in a more budget 5g chip in
here so we're going to see how much
slower it is but i started opening up
geekbench 5 and unfortunately it says
for some reason that it's not compatible
with this phone and then with that
3dmark wildlife also is not compatible
for some reason i don't know what is
going on so we're going to flip it up
we're going to go to passmark's
performance benchmark here we're gonna
run that since it is compatible of
course the iphone 12 has that powerful
a14 with four gigs of ram whereas the
pixel 5a they stuck with the same chip
as last year paired with six gigs of ram
and that chip was actually the weak spot
of the pixel 4a all right we are done
and wow i actually kind of like this new
test maybe we're gonna have to start
using it now we have a big difference
here looks like the cpu we go from
almost 3 000 to almost 9 000 so 3 times
the cpu performance which is crazy but
some of these have a much bigger
difference for example data encryption
we go from 650 megabytes a second to
5820 and as far as the storage speed it
looks like for right we go from 238
megabytes a second to
494 so more than twice as fast as far as
the storage that's something that people
don't usually talk about and for read we
go from about 600 to 767.
now i also want to do a gaming test so
let's go ahead and open up basemark
since it is compatible with both we'll
run the official medium test that way
it's cross compatible with the same
resolution and look at that guys i mean
with the a14 we're playing perfectly
smoothly here it's taking way longer and
just look at that glitchiness it is just
not keeping up and take a look at that
score difference
3337 compared to 17 000 and we have fps
difference uh the average of 33 fps
compared to 171
that is a massive difference in
performance and just because the pixel 5
8 has the same chip as the 4a5g
in geekbench 5 the graphic score goes
from about a thousand to 9000 with the
iphone 12. and then as far as the cpu if
the single core score is 575 compared to
almost 1600 with iphone 12 and the
multi-core score goes from 1500 up to 4
000 which is insane so we definitely
know that the 5a even though it's a
great budget phone do not buy it for
performance if you want to game or do
things that take a lot of cpu power now
the last performance test that i want to
do is the 5g test
this new pixel it no longer supports a
millimeter wave which is fine but i want
to see just how good that 5g is because
a lot of times they can go and cheap out
have poor antennas and it could be
really slow so let's pop in the sim it
looks like the pixel actually has better
reception at least what it's showing we
are on the t-mobile network using ultra
low band um 5g let's go ahead and get
started here we are connecting to the
same server here and look at that speed
difference we're looking at 200 compared
to about 50 for our download speed that
is a massive difference now yes i'm
running both of them at the same time
but usually there's hundreds or
thousands of phones connected to each
tower as far as upload speed not that
big of a difference in fact the pixel is
beating out the iphone we're looking at
about 33 upload compared to 20. now of
course that changes depending on where
you go you will get faster speeds on the
iphone in different areas it's been lots
of upgrades but it looks like yes the
iphone does have the flagship better
modem than the pixel and now for the
cameras we have 12 megapixel shooters on
the front and the rear and we have ultra
whites 12 on the iphone 16 on the pixel
5a now as i mentioned at the start they
got rid of that laser auto focusing
system but of course since it's since
the 4a came out it's been about a year
we've had software updates so i'm really
curious to see how these will compare
we're going to do another blind camera
comparison so if you guys want to see
that those are always a ton of fun click
that circle above to subscribe and to
help us reach our goal of a million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos over there and overall the pixel
it's a great deal it's just a shame they
still stuck with that same chip thanks
for watching has been max and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]